quoi
le gouvernement de fait les couilles a
rempli ses promesses
la réponse pourrait vous surprendre les
citoyens ont trop tendance à ignorer ce
que dans les plateformes et en plus à se
faire l'idée et à y tenir
faire que des politiciens et j'ai
rencontré un groupe de chercheurs de
l'université laval qui va lui
régulièrement les premiers inscrits dans
la plateforme ce parti libéral du québec
en 2014
les résultats sont publiés en ligne se
se nomme le poly m couillard un
indicateur de performance mais où tous
les engagements sont mis sur un même
pied d'égalité
peu importe leur importance cinquante
huit provinces avec le dépôt du budget
2017-2018 la semaine dernière jusqu'ici
42% des promesses ont été tenues dont
celle de réaliser un surplus budgétaire
dès 2015 2005
c'est parce qu'on fait des promesses de
droite action ça fait moins de promesses
à remplir
27% des promesses sont en voie de l'être
ou partiellement réalisés tels que de
compléter le projet du train de l'est et
de l'ouest
il faut accélérer les travaux
d'infrastructures à montréal 20 % sont
en suspens comme cette promesse de créer
250 mille emplois sur un mandat de cinq
ans et 11 pour s'endetter rompu parmi
elles des compressions de 1 milliard 300
millions de dollars au cours des deux
premières années du mandat
oui l'austérité est une promesse mais
elle a été brisée par ce que les
compressions ont été beaucoup plus
important nous faisons exactement
nous avons dit que nous ferions nous
avons fait ce que nous avions dit que
nous ferions
mais le gouvernement de philippe
couillard ne fait pas panda par les
premiers poli mettre sur les
gouvernements de pauline marois et de
stephen harper réalisées à compter de
2012 faisait le même constat les
policiers tiennent leur parole et
répondent à la majorité leur engagement
nos collègues américains anglais suédois
et la belle conclusion
les politiciens tiennent leurs promesses
parce que c'est la chose rationnelle si
on a l'impression dans l'opinion
publique que les gouvernements ne
tiennent pas leurs promesses
il semble selon les chercheurs que ce
soit de notre faute
les médias je pense qu'à un cynisme de
confiance c'est connu la joute partisane
et les enflures verbal de part et
d'autre font souvent l'objet d'une
couverture médiatique bien plus
importante que les bonnes nouvelles
ça vaut plus de sex-appeal de dire up
couillard tient pas ses promesses
le groupe derrière le poly m couillard
associé au consortium de chercheurs
internationaux comprend les parties
plates groupe dit se baser sur une
méthodologie reconnue pour en arriver
aux résultats parfois ce n'est pas
toujours très clair si la promesse du
gouvernement a été remplie ce qui laisse
place à une certaine marge d'erreur bref
ce n'est pas une science exacte
fatalement le croisement avec beaucoup
de sources que au final ce contrat là
qu'on peut faire seul
c'est travail scénique et d'ici la
prochaine saison des promesses
électorales à l'automne 2010 8
la grande question sera de savoir si les
québécois se souviendront des promesses
tenues et non tenues
[Musique]